ma da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo incredibile video di amon grazie
perché nella partita di oggi la che fare
una roba particolare gli impostori ci
saranno ma è compreso ovviamente come
sempre però avranno la visione ridotta
nel senso che vedranno meno le crew
mente questa cosa è molto difficile per
impostori vincere così è un casino ma io
sono io è visto già sfoderando un po le
cose però vabbè buona visione
[Musica]
siamo in true story in una partita dove
è un po particolare perché praticamente
abbiamo settato che gli impostori sono
mezzi c'è chi ce li possono non vedono
niente
porca vacca centrato inventa sbagliato
non ho visto gli impostori ragazzi non
vedono assolutamente nulla e questa cosa
qua è importantissima perché è il
momento di ammazzare proprio adesso
perché ho cercato tutti ok meno male e
l'unico modo per vincere questo raga
hanno riportato rama allora non vedevo
noi vediamo meno degli altri
questo è il discorso raga comunque la
partenza di considerando il fatto che
stiamo giocando una partita dove noi
vediamo veramente poco ragazzi rispetto
agli altri che abbiamo siamo ciechi
siamo partiti benissimo ma benissimo
considerando che siamo veramente c'è chi
sta cosa è pazzesca raga ve lo giuro io
è che noia ce la stiamo giocando
abbastanza bene almeno in partenza
perché comunque fare un achille da
ciechi davanti a tutti che vedono invece
non la vita ma se la vinciamo siamo dei
fenomeni perché è veramente impossibile
vincere sta partita veramente
impossibile vincerla per la saab haute
age io metto fix lights di nuovo io io
io vorrei ma vorrei girare a caso finché
non becco qualcuno e poi mettere tx
lights è di nuovo la gente
non vede come me qua ce n'è però c'è un
sacco di gente a cercare qualcuno che si
sta qua
cos'è peak light peak life's ed ecco
qualcuno lo ammazzo
ok nessuno ma visto perché certi slice
perfetto allora non vedevo allora è
morto se mons terzo davanti a me però
anche noi avevamo la visione piccola
crepa avevamo lajatico davanti a me ho
visto un po visto alcun discorso non so
chi possa essere tran altri siamo e
fabio facciamo così possiamo amarci
perché siamo stimarci viadana perché lo
fai stiamo riuscendo a fare chi
continuamente e siamo ciechi e
bellissima sta roba siano completamente
ciechi e stiamo calando siamo dei
fenomeni sismici ai ragazzi siamo non
vediamo niente se vinciamo sta partita
siamo dei fenomeni ragazzi veramente
allora l'unico modo di continuare un c'è
pian piano mentre uccidiamo è sempre più
facile perché c'è sempre meno gente in
giro o un ovvietà però soprattutto in
questa partita è molto più facile perché
già ci vediamo poco quindi c'è molta
probabilità che qualcuno ci veda anche
per il fatto che noi non vediamo niente
fine volo dagli indubbi chiamata
l'emergenza ma marchi perché stiamo
inseguendo logo con un coltello proprio
in mano si vedeva dopo il coltello in
animazione aspetta ma quindi la cosa mi
ha visto poco sbaglio vistosamente un
pezzo così ho visto totale allora sei tu
che non ci vedi tanto bene aia ha
imposto vedove di ragazzi non ho capito
che stiamo votando no si vede e vuol
dire che li potevamo stare
ok scusate non avevo capito che hai
scusate ma mi si è partita che è partita
ragazzi che è partita
mancano 20 secondi vediamo di riuscire a
fare una roba decente
ok ma qualcosa io che noi siamo qua
dovremo andare a casa secondi 7 6 5 4 3
nessuno viene a fare la task nessuno
viene a fare la tasca per volta da
ciechi grazie dei fenomeni da c'è qui
siamo fenomeni ma basta fortissimi
[Musica]
l'impostore non vede nulla in queste
partite ragazzi questo importante quindi
da capire stiamo giocando in quel
momento dove riposa ecco infatti siamo
in slice quindi chiunque sia
di sicuro non il bianco security prima
che le fix light arrivassero quindi
vediamo cosa succederà che hanno vedo
niente sono completamente cieco anche io
come l'attenzione a temi loco morto al
primo turno mattina 100 300 per ed
elettrica scommetto no l'ho visto lì
dov'era magari io non penso che vada
accolto tale valgano di cielo allora
potreste uccidermi subito dopo e ho
anche paura di fare questa col perché si
tratta di che noia ma per me è che noi
perché è brutto perché io sono nero
inseguiti vicino a loco neve vado giù e
vedo solo che noi a salire ed è morto
breve istantaneamente sempre piacere un
altro il visto
[Musica]
ma lasciano un fabio niente io non lo so
se effettivamente c'era qualcun altro io
ho visto solo che noi paga per me e per
noi italia per me è che noi appunto cioè
era veramente stava salendo mentre io
stavo scendendo per andare a fare pic
slice quindi che noi a 600 per cento
secondo me poi magari mi sbaglio c'era
veramente qualcun altro ma secondo me è
sul serio che noia la smettiamo di
togliere porco del demonio chi è questo
c'è il viola maledette qualcuno sta sta
votando chi era non era il viola
maledizione che ci sta votando
tra di noi l'impostore la per forza in
2015 con l'adesione tordino di posto
allora bam perfetto perfetto c'è matteo
faia che sta sulla ventola no però stava
facendo la trasformista mente lei per e
la porta è chiusa
vediamo qua se c'è qualcuno è morto come
hanno vinto nulla
praga allora erin electrical ok in
questo matteo che stava sulla ventola
allora sono sceso c'è l'affare che era
davanti la porta chiusa e non per la
porta sotto la di elettrica dibatterà
morto sopra ma qui a vent'anni ventato
dall uscita dell'anno diventato io gli
ho visto nate marci non avrei capito
solo a partire da solo anno ventata
ucciso a torino nessuno era in elettrica
guarda chi mi ha votato l'edizione
paralizzò demonia che noia che noia che
noia tutta la vita di un'asta con tania
che noia fate le tasche ma edizione
siano nei ragazzi che noi a 100 100
perché proprio ma neanche se l'altro non
so chi sia mauro dei due per forza che
noia per forza proprio io voglio far
capire voglio far capire a step che non
sono io stiamo lì vicino voglio far
capire che non sono io stando lì vicino
ok
no ci vedevano prossimi episodi ragazzi
per adesso soddisfatto perché sono
veramente soddisfatto di come ho giocato
saranno insieme giusti schede che lascia
un bel commento qua sotto e non ci diamo
come sempre al prossimo vino dell'area
[Musica]